Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Sister Location: Custom Night.
Now were gonna do "Weirdos", and this one doesn't actually seem all that hard.
We only have the Minireena and the Electrobab and then Yenndo and Bonnet.
It's- it's not even any active threats; it's only Yenndo that's the only one that can actually kill you.
And then Lolbit just- you gotta type LOL, or click on the keypad.
Either one does it. You just doodley-doo and he's gone.
So we're gonna go into this and we're gonna smash through these next few ones,
because it seems like they're just an interesting combination as opposed
to anything that might actually be challenging.
The only thing we gotta look out for is Electrobab.
Cause there's nobody at the doors, that's for damn sure.
[Oxygen squeak] Mark: Here we go. [shock]
Mark: Oh. Hello
[Bonnet giggles]
Oh ah fuckin'... wow, okay.
Yenndo might be a bit of a problem if he's gonna that big of a dick to me.
But other than that, not too terribly bad.
That's gonna be weird if Yenndo doesn't go away on the f-
on the second flip up.
Because if he can appear twice in a row... ehh, that's kinda a bit of a problem.
[More squeaking]
[More giggles]
Boink!
But other than that, not too terribly bad.
It might best to actually to get in the habit of double-flipping
the camera as soon as it comes down because you never
know when he might not be there.
But then again, if he's not there then there was
No point doing that and you kind of just wasted some resources.
Oh well, we'll figure it out.
Yeah, there- there's apparently-
I don't think there's a power penalty for doing the controlled shocks, so as soon as...
As soon as it goes up there might be... it might be prudent just to shock right away,
just in case there's something there
'cause you never know; if he's not there, then you just move along with the other one,
and hope that it rolls over [shock]
Yeah, this isn't too bad; this is easy.
This is really easy.
This's like, ri-di-cu-lous-ly easy
COME ON!
Okay, bye-bye.
Yeah, I thought you were gonna give me a challenge here.
I thought this was gonna be difficult, but apparently not.
Hi Yenndo.
Bye Yenndo.
Yeah. It's like, it's like clockwork.
Boink, boink. [Click]
Ohh, Yenndo has a cool-down!
[Click]
Okay, that makes sense. [pls stand by]
HEY, I had'ja!
Go away.
So, it seems that Yenndo has a cool-down and here comes the...
next batch of power-suckers...
[Shock] [Squeaking]
So, the power drain comes at, like, predictable times
Because I'm able to know in my head
Roughly when there should be another one,
And it always overlaps with an oxygen,
if you do it at the right time.
So I'm wondering if everything else can have a predictable pattern, too.
But I'm about to finish this night with the most I've ever had
[Shock, Shock]
in the history of ever.
The only rogue element is if Yenndo doesn't go away
on the first flippity-flap,
but I think that that's...
He DOES go away; that's just him appearing again.
Which is entirely possible.
[Bonnet] Take me with you!
[Celebratory Music] NO.
~Duh, da da, dah~
♫~I'm a win-ner, I'm not taking you with meeee~♫
~Go fuck yourself~
A'right, what else we got here?
I bet it's bad!
Eh, EUGH!
[Happy Midi Music]
♪ Oh, don't look at me ♪
♪ My purple skin is bad! ♪
♪ YOU BETTER HIDE AROUND THE CORNER ♪
♪ Don't get me mad! ♪
♪ No one's gonna save you when I eat all of your faces ♪
♪ Then I'm gonna go along ♪
♪ [ dinosaur noises ] ♪
♪ Can't speak anymore ♪
♪ I got nothing left, buh fluh ♪
♪ [Rhythmic Gargling] ♪
♪ [Disgusted Choking] ♪
♪ [Vomiting] ♪
♪ [Screaming] ♪
♪ [Bird Noises] ♪
♪ [Death] ♪
...Anyway,
That was probably my most cheerful song out of all of that.
We've gooooot...
"Top Shelf," "Bottom Shelf," "Cupcake Challenge"
...well, this is easy...
Alrighty then!
So, the only interesting thing in this one...
...is that it combines Funtime Freddy AND Ballora
So there's two things that you need to listen to.
If there was Bidybab in here, then there'd be THREE things that you'd need to listen to
and that makes it a bit more interesting.
"Cupcake Challenge" also removes that.
Yeah, so the only time that you'd have three things to listen to is actually on "Golden Freddy" mode.
But either way we're gonna roll through this, so "Top Shelf" it is.
Helloooooo~
Hiii~
I'm here now!
oh, boy...
[Funtime Freddy] Well, hello again!
Hi.
[Funtime Freddy]
[Funtime Freddy] Are you ready-y for Round Two?
YES.
[Funtime Freddy] Get ready for a surpriiiise~
Not exactly a surprise.
[Funtime Freddy] Bon-Bon, let's not keep our friend wa-waiting!
[Ballora's Music] Kay, okay.
[Door Slams]
Gettin' a rhythm out of it
Gettin a rhythm
[Funtime Freddy] Oh, Birthday Boyyy~
Not too bad; this is easy.
This is manageable.
Because it's just determining on whether or not
ohp
Still there? Okay.
'der-ter-ming' on whether or not Ballora's actually getting close,
or not.
[Funtime Freddy] Anybody home?
Which is gonna require absolute silence
on MY part
because I...am a blathering idiot.
[Funtime Freddy] Go g-get 'em!
NO.
[Ballora's Music] Dooh buh dooh dooh dooh
DOOH
duhr
DOOH dooh
DOOH
Dooh duhr
[Door Slams]
deh
DOOH
dah
Gonna make it, yeahh
Hell yeah, gonna make it, yeah
I am gonna...
Hub
DOO
BOO, deh, deh-buh geh-duh boo...
BOO, deh-buh doo-buh doo...
DOO
BIRD-uh
DEH-duh
BOO~
DOO
BIRD-uh
DEH-duh
BOO~
DEH
BIRD-uh
doodle doo...
Doodle
bah-dle
doodle
boo...
DUH.
Doo
dah-dle
boodle
doo
DUH.
Boo
dah-dle
boodle
doo...
DAH.
...do do do Here come mah victory
here come mah victory
Here come mah victory.
Here BETTER come mah victor....
[Funtime Freddy] What a party pooper!
One percent left; I'm the best.
I did that even with three
pur- three
thur three
fifty percent out of Three A.M.
[Gibberish]
~Yay, I did it~
I said words correctly and stuff and things.
So how's this gonna devolve?
EH.
[Happy Midi Music]
Eh-HEH.
♪ Well, this ain't so good ♪
♪ I've felt better ♪
♪ I dunno what I'm doing ♪
♪ Everybody's hidin' from me ♪
♪ I got no friends ♪
♪ No one here ta' love me ♪
♪ I'm just a purple guy ♪
♪ A-with no shirt ♪
♪ What happened to me? ♪
♪ We could be so happy ♪
Oh, man...
Jee-hee-heez
Oh.
euuuuugGGGGHHHHH
Ehh-
OOOOUUUUHH!
WHAT
THE
FFFUCK
ing
FFFUCK?!
[Ennard/Baby] You won't die
You won't die (die)
You won't die
[Mark] Uhh...
Oh!
OH!
Oh, okay!
OHH!
HO-O-O, OKAY?!
SHUUUUUUURE!
God-damn, that rocketed out of your body like nobody's business!
So what did that mean?
That's the interesting question that I have
What does that mean?
I mean, I understand the fundemental concept of ''You won't die''
and therefore Purple Guy was not....
....just the combination....
....of the two of them....
Purple Guy is now the re surr ected evil version of the scooped-out entity that was....
Purple guy.
I-UHHHH
That's fucking weird. Uhmm....
Okay, so, if I had to fully....
If I had to fully rationalize what I just saw....
So, Purple Guy....
is.....literally empty inside
because all of the innards were scooped to make the way for Ennard.
So in that capacity, Purple Guy is like this soulless, heartless, completely empty shell
....of a man.
Who likely isn't a man.
Who's somehow kept alive after they were transformed
....by having Ennard inside of them.
And when it finally came time for Ennard to leave
After...maybe Ennard discovered that it wasn't working
the changes have been so severe
And Ennard's promise that....
You wouldn't die....
....came to life in that something was left behind.
Not mechanically in terms of, like....
litterally left behind in Purple guy,
But something a bit more....
I dunno. Above that.
Something....horrible....was left behind.
And who you were in Sister Location was changed forever
And just this hollow....
....empty, walking shell....
.....was left behind
and that's who Purple Guy was.
And maybe that's....
Man, maybe that's why Purple Guy constantly felt the need to fill the empty void..
Inside the hollow shells of his animatronic friends.
throughout the rest of Five Nights at Freddy's
That's just a thought.
But it's an interesting thought.
So, anyway.
So, I dunno if there's more to that, but, wow...ugh
Alright, let's try the Bottom Shelf.
Should be just as easy.
All there's to it is the people on my face...
......and Bidybab.
And that's it. That's literally it.
This is so easy.
God, this is so easy. SOOOO EASEEEEHH!
ah ha
[Bidybab] I don't want to play hide and seek
*creepy voice* Don't you?
[Bidybab] I'm going to find a way inside!
Okay. Do that.
uh huh
Oh, you didn't do it? ok.
That's too bad for you.
The only thing-
-literally, the only thing-
-that makes this particular one difficult....
....is the fact that I can't see the L-O-L keys behind my microphone.
I literally have to guess.
But I'm nailing it every time, 'cause I'm just that badass.
[Shock]
Hell yeah.
[Bidybab][Stubbornly] I'm gonna get inside!
Uh
NO YOU'RE NOOOOT!
DA DA DA DA DA DADA DA DADADAAA
I AM THA WINNER AND YOU'RE NOOOOOOT
Okay. I don't know if there's going to be another cutscene. *gibberish*
nope, oohkay, so that's the only cutscene that we got
So the only thing left on our list-
-and that was super easy-
Is......the cupcake challenge
and Golden Freddy-mode.
Man, that would be the easiest thing in the world.
How is this very hard?
HOW IS THAT HARD!?!?
THAT'S NOT HARD AT ALL!!!!
That's easy. You don't even have Yenndo in there.
Let's give it a GO!!!!
Just gotta listen for Ballora and uh Fun-aTimma Freddeh~
But even they're not running at maximum capacity.
[Shock]
[Funtime Freddy] Ready or not, here I come!
[Click]
[Shock]
Yeah, this is definitely going to be more hectic
Not impossible....
....but certainly hectic.
Okay. We're not doing too terribly.
We may not win on this one-
Ah, we - actually, we might win on this one.
We're pretty close.
We're sitting at 49% at 3 AM
[Funtime Freddy} Bon Bon, lets not keep our friend waiting
Really not that bad.
For first time on this one.
[Shock]
I just gotta be better about getting
-Oh, shit. Goddammit.
Getting exactly what I was talking about there.
Getting the, uh-the power ones.
Yeah, we're cutting it pretty close but we're actually doing better than we just did.
If we can keep up this pace....
....we MIGHT be able to make it through.
But it's gonna be just barely if we do.
[Shock] [Shock] [WARNING FOR WEAK OF HEART]
WHOA! FUCKING WHAT!?
I got your nose!
Ah, dammit. It's ok.
I-E-O-I....must've....must've forgot about them when I was flipping the camera up and down.
Okay. So that wasn't TOO bad.
I can do this.
Lemme just go back in there.
I know that Scott himself has said that it's actually literally impossible to beat ''Golden Freddy'' on 20-mode.
Which....I dunno....I dunno...
I honestly don't know, like, how capable he is at beating games.
I would imagine he's pretty dang good
considering....
He made the game-god, how long is that up?
Man, I probably just fucked myself over
Because I was talking and-
FUCKING FUCK!
Yeah, that's why! Yeah, that!
I remember why I put up that door.
I was to keep her out.
Ahhhh, fuck.
I gotta stop talking. I could've beat that easy, but, y'know....
I was just trying to talk
But anyway. I'll finish what I was gonna say.
Scott himself has said that he has not been able to beat 20-mode
He has not been able to beat Golden Freddy-mode on Very Hard.
and I'm imagining he's probably pretty good at the game, considering he made it.
But whether that means it's impossible??...
....Is up in the air, like, who's to say.
We don't know if he's the BEST player of all time and I'm not claiming-
-To BE the best Five Nights at Freddy's player
But I am pretty damn persistent.
So if I can't beat it....
....then I don't know what I'm gonna do.
I'm probably gonna know if I can't beat it after a few hours of attempts.
But I gotta get through this first, so let me just do this, no talking, and then....
I'll be good to go.
*Ballora's haunting music plays*
[Shock]
[Funtime Freddy] B-BonBon, go ge-get 'em!
[Funtime Freddy] BonBon, lets not keep our friend wa-wai-ting!
*Click*
[Shock]
So, I've noticed-
I just wanna say real quick-
that the ElectroBabs are always gonna be in the opposite-
Are always gonna be in the opposite corner than the uhm-Funtime Freddy is.
Sorry. Of course it gets crazy when I'm trying to talk about something.
*Click*
Of course it does.
[Shock]
So he's always in the opposite. That's something to note.
Mostly for myself. Not for you guys. Unless you guys wanna pick up something from that.
In that case you can totally do that.
*Click*
*Ballora's music continues to play*
[Funtime Freddy] Knock-knock! Is anybody home?
*Ballora's music plays, varying in volume*
Doin' good.
I think I'm gonna-[Funtime Freddy] What a party pooper!-Yep. Got it. Easy!
Once I stop, y'know, BLABBERING MY BIG FAT PIE HOLE....
I suddenly realized all this skill inside my soul.
And there's not gonna be another....
Not gonna be another-crack at tha...
good ol' cutscene.
But, alas, the only thing we have left to do is Golden Freddy-mode
Which should be....
*Shrieking* Probably a bit of a bitch!
People have been saying that easy....is....not so easy, but doable.
Normal is pretty hard
And then Hard is the real challenge here.
Uhm....people are saying that Very Hard-mode is impossible
But I'm not a 100% sure about that.
Who knows? Maybe it's just that no one has beat it yet.
Let me give it one go.
I'm n'a
Just one old gander with all of my skill intact.
I don't know how this is gonna go.
We shall see.
[Funtime Freddy] Well, hello again! Mark: Hello.
[Funtime Freddy] *Mad cackling* Are you ready for round two?
Nope. I sure am not.
[Funtime Freddy] BonBon, let's not keep our friend wai-waiting!
[Shock]
[Funtime Freddy] Hey BonBon, Go ge-get'em!
Oh, boy. *Yenndo screams* Okay. That was-yep, that was pretty dang hard.
I....kinda....man, Yenndo makes that a problem.
But either way, that's gonna be a son of a bitch to attempt.
I'm gonna try it, though.
I'm not sure if I'm gonna try, y'know, to dive into Hard and then go to Very Hard.
What I'm pretty sure I'm gonna do is; I'm gonna try to hammer away at Very Hard first.
And if I can do that-
Or if I CAN'T do that-
Then I'm going to go down to Hard.
But we shall see. That is for another day.
And by ''Day'' I mean I'm literally gonna dedicate a full day to trying this sack-a-shit.
So either way,  thank you everybody so much for watching!
And let me know what you thought down in the comments below.
And as always, I will see YOU....
....in the next video!
BUH-BYE!
*dubstep outro music*